thank you
[Music]
all right you guys have seen video this
it's been going around super viral
really big in Asian Community it's the
first place I saw it uh but a Vietnamese
smoke shop owner in Las Vegas
stabs a teen robber seven times
oh that thing I saw this in the knife
Community I'm a big part of the knife oh
you're part of the knife Community what
about the knife Asian Community I'm not
a part of that okay are you more of a
fixed Trader like a uh also I think it's
important to first note that like nobody
knew he was a teen you know what I mean
what what that doesn't make it sound
like so much more worse it makes it
sound like a guy defending himself was
like [ __ ] up but like realistically
he's still a robber right no the cat was
completely covered up because when you
watch when you watch just the the guy
hopping over the stand and then him
getting stabbed that's one thing when
you watch the whole video collectively
then it's a little different where like
I realized I was like oh these guys look
like young kids that have never robbed
anything before I could tell you what I
what I thought when I watched it so when
I first watched it
um I don't know what to make of it
because like none of the text or
whatever was going to give away the
ending right yeah so when I see the
robbers come in I was like
[ __ ] is this another [ __ ] like Asian
hate video where the Asian guy gets
destroyed [ __ ] killed or murdered or
straight shot in the head for no reason
yeah so I see this guy and then it's two
on one so okay this is already not good
odds really bad odds and then you see
the guy jump over the [ __ ] counter
and I'm like oh man this guy's dying for
sure because that's like the last 300
videos I've seen yeah so to see a dude
stand up for himself and then just react
immediately my initial like gut feeling
was like thank God someone is standing
up and uh teaching this person a lesson
or whatever that's like initially what I
just had with just the quick snippet
that I saw yeah well the thing is when I
saw even the longer clip
yes like you start to realize that these
these two kids are straight up like
juvenile right like they're young they
don't really know what they're doing but
you also kind of get a sense that this
dude uh the owner the Vietnamese dude is
giving them an out yeah he is he's like
he's like he looks at me they're wearing
ski mask he's like why are you guys
wearing those masks yeah because
everyone didn't see that he literally
says honestly just get out of here and
then the guy grabs the cup of coins and
he's like dude just take the mugs you
can leave the coins he's giving them
[ __ ] outs yeah because he was like
can you just leave the change because I
need that yeah because
um I think most of us saw the the
shortened video where the guy just jumps
over the counter and then he stabs right
and then they released the whole
interaction when the guys come in he
comes to the front of the counter and he
goes why you guys wearing those masks
and there's a third guy holding the door
open so the auto lock doesn't engage
right oh so there was actually three on
one there's three yeah so as the two
guys right now the third guy let's go
over the door and follows him and he
also did say you're right he's like can
you get out of here yeah and then they
just kind of wander around and I also uh
read an interview because I was trying
to follow up on it because you know
there's so much information going on and
you're kind of just like did the guy die
what happened blah blah
um and the the smoke shop person who's
working the Vietnamese guy he even says
in an interview that he's like I don't
know if he's strapped or not yeah
exactly exactly yeah no why you know
what I mean but it is dangerous to pull
a knife out on a gunfight dude yeah
totally totally but right like the same
thing like I think most people probably
either like choke up and not know what
to do but at the end of the day you
can't pretend like you know your life
isn't in danger in that situation like
Bart said like oh man the immediate
thought is like oh [ __ ] it's supposed to
be a blasted this agent is gonna get
destroyed again like that that's already
a [ __ ] up yeah as soon as the guy
hopped the counter I was like oh [ __ ]
that's I think everyone's reaction is
like because you usually see videos
where guys hop the counter they put a
gun in someone's head whatever happens
it's like like that's when [ __ ] gets
real but before that it's like oh if
someone points a gun they probably
aren't going to pull the trigger it's
just like give me your [ __ ] and they
leave but then but how do you know that
in most videos that we see like they
don't they don't I know I know what
you're saying but I'm saying like
Destroyer it was you it's like but then
when they hop the counter there's a lot
of violence that goes down where they
repeatedly beat them yeah yeah I've seen
all that so then that's when I go oh
[ __ ] they hopped it because there's
gonna be a struggle if you hop together
for sure and then also for this guy he's
probably seen so much [ __ ] that's
happened in the store you know did you
see anything that said if that's not the
first time it's happened oh I don't know
because he he was acting like that [ __ ]
he was trained or something that's what
I mean like he's probably been in that
situation this was in Vegas right yeah I
was in Vegas also like the thing is it's
like a privately owned business too
right like I can understand that if
you're an employee at maybe like a
multi-chain type establishment there's
it's not your thing there's Insurance in
place it's like hey if you know you
don't need to be a cada in a situation
is going to put your life in danger blah
blah but like when when it's a private
business like everything that's on the
line it's your liability as well you
know like you gotta I guess if you're I
guess I'm talking to all the robbers out
there the would-be robbers it's like you
got to pay attention to you know like
what you're trying to even do because
like you go into a private establishment
you don't [ __ ] know [ __ ] about those
people you go to CVS you know they're
not gonna [ __ ] retaliate yeah no or
rush like they're not gonna fly that
store could have been something where
they put their entire life savings in
and borrowed from all their aunts and
uncles to make a Dream Work yeah so for
them they're like I need to protect this
at all it doesn't matter because the
owner should have done the most perfect
thing ever right he should have known
exactly what the rules of engagement are
should have known exactly what to do in
this moment we could have cut the ankles
up why don't they just [ __ ] [ __ ] just
go for the legs you have to kill them
that is a hot take though because like
you know obviously this thing is going
super viral so when you look at all like
the comments in different places it I
mean it's not it's not super divided but
there are there are people there's
definitely people that are kind of like
you know this guy took it too far why do
you have to send same time oh my God
he's 17. it's like you don't [ __ ]
know yeah I know in most self-defense
courses if you're met with a threat you
have to assume the worst yeah this guy
has done this before is the ex-felon
this guy looks way taller than the other
dude like you don't go oh this guy must
be prepubescent or some [ __ ] you know
you gotta immediately go the worst you
have to assume the worst so you could
protect yourself and act accordingly and
to from my opinion I think he did a
really good how many stories do you have
to read where it's like hey um the guy
jumps the counter he takes the goods and
then he blows the guy away anyway that
happens we've seen it we've all seen it
over like negligible amounts of money
this is what I don't get too is like
people go is it really worth a life and
I'm like what about the initiator what
about the guy that came in with the gun
was it worth it he thought it was worth
the life yeah he's like thinking I'll
kill you for this [ __ ] 20 dollar a
bill like so I'm like why why can't that
that be reciprocated to the [ __ ]
aggressor I don't know why that even I
say it's 20 20. and then it's like oh
well you should be the bigger person and
use soft Jiu Jitsu skills was that
opinion is that like a lifelong opinion
that is always existing there's a lot of
people that believe that they go oh well
you don't have to stoop to their level
just because
no that's not new it's been around why
does it feel like I [ __ ] it feels new
because there's no ring cameras
everywhere there's footage everywhere so
now you can actually watch or crime back
and judge it yourself but I also think
how many of those people that are
writing those comments as [ __ ] kibo
Warriors have been in that same
situation zero zero and their Guam sucks
too for keyboard Warriors the [ __ ]
Guam is horrible they're words a minute
dude they can't type that fast even the
little [ __ ] they're little [ __ ]
about speed on the [ __ ] keyboard even
they're like typing like this dude a lot
of people that say this [ __ ] right what
I've noticed in the comments is like
when people have been robbed when
they've been [ __ ] beat and left on
the street like they see this and they
go oh hell yeah I wish I could have done
that yeah yeah and in the ones that live
in gated ass communities and never
[ __ ] solve violence in their lives
they're like violence is not the answer
they got so many opinions too but you
hear guys like like the Jocko will mix
or the the Tim Kennedy is the guys
who've actually like killed people and
have been in the field they always say
most people don't know the true reality
of violence and sometimes it's like yeah
you don't want to see that [ __ ]
obviously if you're at home in your
living room scrolling on Instagram
they'll follow Jackfruit yeah exactly
but at the same time it's like it's like
this dude felt threatened enough for him
to take action
he's like look I you know a lot of
people they don't know violence I know
violence I'm Dick Cheney I shot a guy on
the [ __ ] face yeah I [ __ ] put a
drone on a [ __ ] family of four I
don't give a [ __ ] and uh that that guy
apparently the the 17 year old kid
um you know he only had two more things
to say after I'm dead I'm dead when uh
the Vietnamese dragged him too closer
towards the door and he literally said
um this wasn't my idea that was the
first thing he said yeah and then the
second being said is please don't let me
die sir and the Vietnamese dude calls
the the cops in that wow yeah and he's
just trying to keep him alive so is
there a confirmation if the kid passed
or no I don't think last thing I read
was he's alive I mean this is an article
I'm looking announced five hours ago and
it doesn't say he died it just says he
it's unclear but like that's I mean I've
never been in that situation but from my
point of view that seems like a normal
concept of protocol protect protect
yourself from your establishment and
then after you successfully protect
yourself it's like all right this guy
has been just neutralized like let me
call the [ __ ] cops like yeah right
and he dragged him a couple feet closer
to the hospital and this kid he's 17
right he knows that going to a place
like this is not is not a good thing to
do no especially like a smoke shop a lot
of those guys expect to be robbed a lot
yeah couple was going straight for the
blunts a lot of those guys are like
ready for [ __ ] like that if you do that
it's kind of [ __ ] dumb like yeah why
would you put your life on the line if
your life is Tough Enough where you got
to steal something and you know what
like let's try and be empathetic that
maybe it's tough for a lot of people you
know what I mean if you're gonna steal
something not if you're doing smoke shop
[ __ ] like I feel like if I'm gonna steal
something I'm gonna steal like food yeah
dude it's either straight up food or
straight up money I'm not gonna steal a
blunt roller you know like what the [ __ ]
go to Target and just steal everything
dude I do it all the time I'm in there
with a trash bag they're insured yeah
gold insurance
but I wonder what's going to happen
because
um Nevada is more of a protect your
business your house kind of situation if
this was in California a thousand
percent this guy would be doing [ __ ]
life in prison right now apparently so
far there's been like no charges or
anything on this guy and uh I think I
read a Sim the same article or whatever
like the news reporters were trying to
reach out to the Las Vegas PD in that
area to see if there was any comments or
any updates but so far nothing is going
against the uh I also hope he doesn't
feel like mentally [ __ ] from this [ __ ]
either
you know like some people people always
feel they don't they don't feel for the
murderer you know
they don't always consider like what the
stabber thinks you know and that's
[ __ ] up yeah because he he had that's
a lot of emotions like to be stabbing
and stabbing like that he won't look at
his knife the same no he'll be like you
work it's like that one kid you know
that one kid who shot the mass shooter
yeah and his family was like we just are
praying that he doesn't have nightmares
yeah because he did a good thing yeah
ultimately wait a kid shot a life in the
mall yeah oh the one in oh oh yeah yeah
yeah but it's like you know like killing
someone's not something normal to go
through you know especially if you
didn't want to do it yeah there's also a
weird thing to take pride in you know
what I mean like or be a hero of right
because that's like at the end of the
day but this dude did post this video
himself that's the first way it got out
I I don't know apparently that's what we
were all talking about earlier but how's
the 17 year old is he alive or it
doesn't say it but it doesn't say he's
dead nothing says he's dead so I think
it's yeah good to assume he's still
alive at the moment however one of the
top comments said his mama gonna be
wiping his ass for the rest of his life
but that's you know that's a jackfruit's
fault enabling them comments you know
what I'm saying I wonder what next shark
comments have to say about this
thank you